et un court métrage coup de poing
tournai ath et free minds originaire de
la région son comédien principal a
maintenant à laisser passer pour les
oscars c'est vraiment ce qu'on peut pas
on peut quasiment parler plus loin que
cela elles font peut pas aller plus haut
et caceres la nature des roches prouver
la troublante histoire de deux garçons
qui se livrent à des jeux malsains
le court métrage a raflé près de 60 prix
mais une nomination aux oscars
c'est l'apothéose pour son réalisateur
je peux dépasser par tout seul ce
domaine tellement nouveau pour moi
nominé aux oscars the central tellement
lointain obscures on a sauté de joie
qu'ont appris la nouvelle c'est
complètement incroyable c'est comment
faire l'amour enfin un deuxième court
métrage de fiction produit au québec est
aussi en lice margerit réalisé par une
autodidacte porte un regard sur
l'homosexualité d'une femme âgée qui a
enfoui son secret ça c'est extra en
avoir le nom de son film à l'écran j'ai
crié j'ai
c'est indescriptible en fait ce moment
le tubik lazio c'est la toute première
fois que deux courts métrages de fiction
réalisée au québec se retrouvent en même
temps aux oscars une occasion en or pour
le distributeur de ses films tout est
possible rendu là on pourrait intéresser
les grandes plateformes les netflix de
ce monde
les diffuseurs internationaux fac rendu
là je pense que tout est possible puis
on a de voir ce qu'ils sont répandus
dans les prochaines heures prochaines
semaines louées nerf obtient aussi une
nomination dans la catégorie court
métrage d'animation avec le film
zoothérapie réalisé par un couple de la
colombie britannique qui avait déjà
remporté un oscar en 1995
c'est vraiment particulier cette année
que les astres s'alignent de cette façon
l'hadopi et 3,3 production en même temps
bon c'est vraiment vraiment fabuleux
fabuleux tout à fait est une preuve que
les créateurs d'ici se distingue ce sont
peut-être les dolan villeneuve vallée de
demain qu'on voit effectivement nous
représenter dans cette course aux oscars
en 2019
j'en suis très content vous pouvez voir
ces courts métrages qui se rendront aux
oscars gratuitement sur internet
zoothérapie sera bientôt disponible sur
le site de l'ol f
marguerite et sur tou.tv et pauvres est
en ligne sur vimeo
ici nous et que les couilles mais
radio-canada montréal